[Music]
needless to say I keep my shoe back
let's go yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whole easy mission I'll you miss me I
still live me
[Music]
seriously dad Walken would have been
fine spider I mean this guy swings in
once today zip zap zop in his little
mask and answers to Noah right
yeah dad yeah I love you miles no dad
dad I love you God for copy my name is
Peter B Parker and for the last 22 years
I thought I was the one and only
spider-man I'm pretty sure you know the
rest
you see I saved the city fell in love I
saved the city some more maybe too much
they're like 15 years pass blah blah
blah I buried that may my wife and I
split up but I handled it like a
champion flash-forward I'm in my
apartment doing push-ups doing ad
crunches getting strong when this weird
thing happened and I gotta say weird
things happen to me a lot but this
what are you doing but Oh relax your
fingers we don't have time just just let
go
be in the moment I am in the moment it's
a terrible one there right there they're
gonna see you you gotta unstick what do
you do to relax teenagers just the worst
miles where did you go oh yeah where I
can't see you I'm right in front of you
can spider-man turn invisible not my
universe you just poked me in my eye
this is incredible some kind of
fight-or-flight thing
what's that Oh acts super normals
electing a bagel spider-man you know
that's funny
I get that a lot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and with your hips before you wanted to
hit
[Music]
double tap to release and twist it out
again and release it release your nap
[Applause]
[Music]
we're a little tease me is the teacher
who could still do it you as the student
who can they're just not as good I'm
proud of us Peter
[Music]
Wow
hey guys Wanda its Gwen actually oh you
know her very cool
I'm from another dimension I mean
another another dimension hey guys
Wanda it's Gwen actually oh you know her
very cool I'm from another dimension I
mean another another dimension all right
people let's start at the beginning
my name is Gwen Stacy for the last two
years I've been the one and only spider
grunt I joined the band save my dad
[Music]
one day this weird thing happened and I
mean like really weird
I was blown into last week literally I
landed in New York but not mine New York
let's go
how many more spotty people are there
save it for Comic oh what's Kamakura oh
yeah I got my knees too there's a little
shed where I keep my spider gear
[Music]
in this place pretentious
[Music]
I was like this but take away the Jeep
planned imagine it way smaller imagine a
futon kingpin knows we're coming
we're going to be outnumbered don't be
so sure you might need these
[Music]
do you think you're the only people
who've had to come here
hey fellas it's even black and white
where's that wind coming from we're in a
basement wherever I go they win follows
in the wind
it smells like rain this could literally
not get any weirder it can get weirder I
just washed my hands that's why they're
wet no other reason okay
my name is Peter Parker that's the gig
kind of we're trustees a big look out
here comes the spider hair
[Music]
spider-man into the spider-verse what a
pig
I'm right here only in theaters December
14th rated PG
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait so how many of us hurry
my name is Miles Morales and in my world
I'm the one and only spider-man that is
until he showed up and it snow on the
Cape I think it's cool spider-man
doesn't wear a cape hey guys who are you
I'm Gwen Stacy I'm from another another
dimension
how many more Spidey people are there
hey tell us
this could literally not get any weirder
it can get weirder
my name is Peter Parker I supposed to
save the whole world
you can't think about saving the world
you have to think about saving one
person miles where did you go
spider-man turn invisible not in my
universe this is incredible some kind of
fight or flight thing what's that I
think this is a cape we gotta go no
personal chauffeur gone okay seriously
dad
Walken would have been fine breaking
news spider-man saves the day I guess
spider-man this guy swings in once the
day's zip zap zop guys don't cops run
red lights oh yeah some do but uh not
your dad in your universe there's only
one spider-man but there's another
universe it looks the sounds like yours
but it's not my name is Miles Morales
thank you you like me
I knew my day would come around this
time I know it's complicated
you want to know what happened to you I
can teach you to be spider-man hmm I
love this burger so delicious one of the
best burgers I've ever had
you have money right I'm not very liquid
right now I think you're gonna be a bad
teacher how am I supposed to save the
whole world you can't think about state
in the world you have to think about
saving one person one thing I know for
sure don't do it like me do it like you
[Applause]
[Music]
just see the spark in you it's amazing
paired up whatever you choose to do with
it you'll be great
I love you miles yeah I know that you
gotta say I love you back how do you
series I want to hear it you want to
hear dad I love you gotta copy just like
I thought when did you teach me that I
didn't it's a little joke the
team-building hey guys okay who are you
i'm gwen stacy
people are there same as a comic-con
what's co my name is Peter Parker I'm
pretty sure you know the rest I saved
the city fell in love then I saved the
city again and again and again
I'm a comic-book cereal and get a
Christmas album and it's soso popsicle
but this isn't about me not anymore
spider-man swings in once a day zip zap
zop in his little mask and answers to no
one I love you morons dad are you
serious I wanted here dad I love you Oh
God
[Music]
my name is Miles Morales I'm the one and
only spider-man at least that's what I
thought yeah be here for super collider
you're gonna love this
you're like me that's impossible
alright kid listen up this part is your
universe
soggy it's weird it's gross and this
delicious normal fry is my universe so
you want to learn to be spider-man
Keeney teacher yes I can time to swing
good double tap to release and quit it
out again whip and release your natural
quit hey guys who are you I'm Gwen Stacy
I'm from another another dimension
how many more spider people are there
hey fellas
this could literally not get any weirder
it can get weird okay we need to get
back to our universes soon
Brooklyn is gonna collapse my family
lives in Brooklyn
[Music]
it's mine if I don't destroy the
collider none of us will have a home to
go home to
remember what makes you different that's
all
is what makes you spider-man
officer I love you wait
[Music]
that way that way other way other way
other way
do animals talk in this dimension cuz I
don't want to freak him out
[Music]
[Applause]
you